open borders open markets an
interconnected world but has the
coronavirus and great lockdown made all
that history globalists they're people
that think we have to make the world
wealthy and our expense I don't even
know where these people come from but
those days are over as the world economy
slumps into recession
what sort of system will rise from the
ashes of this crisis for years
there's been a growing backlash against
globalization now the virus has put the
entire system at risk question is for
better or worse
this shop is like a mini universe with
dozens of different versions of our
planet a good place to pause for thought
what's happening to our world is the
corona virus killing globalization
observers say were facing three
scenarios first at the end of an era in
an interview French president among
whalemen crawl said we have to think the
unthinkable and that globalization is
reaching the end of its cycle but if
this a watershed moment in this scenario
politicians and industrialists withdraw
behind their borders companies localized
supply chains repatriate manufacturing
and stockpile supplies some leaders have
been calling for nationalism for a while
the future does not belong to globalists
the future belongs to patriots the
future belongs to sovereign and
independent nations some say that's
nonsense they expect things to pick up
where they left off in this scenario the
world goes back to what it does best
turbo capitalized high volume high speed
trade the intricate networks of supplies
of goods and profits have proven
themselves for many travel and data
transfers have never been so easy why
change that
when I was there globalization is an
external factor it's not to blame for
the virus so it's hard to imagine
everyone would go without the benefits
of globalization due to something from
beyond the system to put pressure on
finances prices and costs and so the
wheel keeps turning after all how can
you simply divorce the world from
globalization people talk a lot about
decoupling or they talk about the end of
globalization and its really a buzzword
that has very little practical meaning
the internet financial flows the way
supply chains are constructed it's very
difficult to think of a future where all
of that is eliminated difficult yes
but impossible some analysts point to a
potential reshaping of globalization a
new normal founded on morals and reason
the crisis could be the moment to push a
green economy a global Green Deal we've
seen how the climate can be protected
and the coronavirus has shaken us out of
complacency towards nature as well at a
moment where things are in flux there's
a lot of uncertainty anything could
happen
that window will will close in you know
in the next six to six months to a year
and then we'll be just back to wherever
we land after that period so does the
world see the pandemic merely as a
crisis that needs to be mastered or as
an opportunity
the mere fact the question is being
posed shows how far the parameters of
our world have shifted
and for more let's bring in viata yeah
Borat chick she's professor of economics
at the University of Oxford and chief
economist at the European Bank for
Reconstruction and Development it's good
to have you with us so what would you
say to an extent is the pandemic ringing
in the end of the global economic system
the way we know it the pandemic hit at
the time when the global economic system
has been under threat the World Trade
Organization has been weakened the
us-china trade war has not finished the
tensions between the US and China may
reignite at any moment so the biggest
threat to globalization is not coming
from the pandemic itself but rather from
the policy changes that may follow that
what you mentioned exactly the pandemic
is actually enhancing protectionism that
we've seen already before however does
becoming less dependent on countries
like China actually makes sense business
sense
well the pandemic will change the way we
think about global value chains in the
early days of the pandemic the world
suddenly became aware of how dependent
we are on China in terms of parts and
components in terms of medical equipment
in terms of antibiotics or ingredients
into for medications and I think the
world will now want to move away from
this concentration of suppliers towards
more resilience so we're going more
local and of course that does not just
apply for goods because globalization is
not just about moving Goods it's also
about moving people and ideas do you
think they'll still be a room for that
in a post corona economy well I don't
think we will necessarily go more local
I think when we think about global value
chains which have been optimized for
cost and which work beautifully if all
parts of the chain worked like clockwork
we've seen that during pandemic when
various countries going lock downs at
various points in time the whole system
breaks down
so the pendulum will switch from
cost-cutting to resilience will move
from just in time to just in case
and that means changing the geography of
supply chains building in redundancy
having more than one suppliers could
could it be that people could actually
benefit from that because you say it
worked wonderfully but globalization was
was harshly criticized for leaving many
many people behind so is now the perfect
time to to take a different attitude
towards work and and making a living
well we all have been thrown into this
giant experiment of remote work from one
day to another I mean many people have
been working remotely for part of the
time but there was a lot of hesitation
bosses were concerned that workers would
not work hard when at home and workers
were concerned that they would be passed
on for possible promotions if they don't
see their boss on daily basis now many
weeks into remote work first know
whether this setup works for them or not
but once you cross this psychological
threshold is border into remote work why
constrain yourself with local workers
why a firm in London or Berlin should
rely on workers based in the UK or
Germany why not hire somebody from
Poland or Romania so paradoxically
actually this shift may not be good for
local workers in advanced countries but
it may benefit countries with lower
wages for skilled workers at the same
time of course the pandemic has shown
that an awful lot of jobs and business
models are obsolete or certainly at risk
is now the time to discuss a basic
income I think after the pandemic we
will certainly have a conversation about
the social contract what it is that we
expect from this state in many countries
the social contract has relied on people
paying
in taxes and expecting little from the
state now I think people will want the
state to ensure the risk people will
want this state to provide more so
perhaps people will not go all the way
to basic universal basic income but
certainly the social contract is bound
to change towards more provision from
the state and naturally higher taxes all
right well let's let's wait and see what
the post corona world has in store for
us professor Beata yeah berchik thank
you so much for your time thank you
Monica
time for your questions now over to our
science correspondent Derek Williams
experts say if you eat meat from an
animal carrying the virus its destroyed
in the digestive tract so how does it
get into your respiratory system in
previous epidemics with corona viruses
like SARS and MERS transmission didn't
occur through food and to date there
have been no confirmed cases where
somebody contracted kovat 19 through
through eating meat so catching it that
way looks unlikely especially if the
meat is is cooked the Assumption
therefore is that the first person or
people who caught the virus didn't get
it from from eating an animal host but
by either being exposed via the air to
the living breathing animal as it shed
virus or through physical contact with a
dead one that's why there's been such a
focus on the wet market in wuhan
associated with the start of this
outbreak live and dead animals from the
wild were sold there after jumping
species to us
SARS co2 didn't need animal hosts to
spread any more it started passing from
human to human the staying inside weaken
your immune response because you aren't
being exposed to as many microbes
there's lots of evidence that spending
too much time indoors isn't great for
your immune system not least because
exposure to sunlight
vitamin D which is involved in the
immune response and and lockdowns can
affect things like the amount of
exercise you get or your sleeping
patterns which which also play major
roles in in overall health but but is
the immune system like a muscle that
wastes away if it's not regularly
challenged by pathogens it's it's true
that people like astronauts who are
confined for long periods can have
immune response problems but but don't
forget that they're also exposed to
things like like high levels of
radiation and weightlessness and even in
lockdown our isolation isn't like it is
for someone in space after all you still
have to get out and go to the store
every once in a while
so the general expert consensus seems to
be that the effects of lower exposure to
pathogens on your immune system should
be pretty negligible at least for a few
months is it true that those who've
recovered from cough in 19 have major
liver damage the health authorities
report that some people hospitalized for
kovat 19 do have increased levels of the
liver enzymes linked to liver damage
some estimates say almost half of all
patients could have those elevated
levels but but it still isn't clear
whether the rise is caused directly by
the virus invading the organ or whether
it's a collateral effect may be caused
by medications or or possibly the
patient's own immune response so current
research hasn't confirmed direct liver
damage that's unmistakably attributable
to tesora Skov - and and the kind of
acute damage you're talking about
certainly hasn't been reported in a
widespread way among people who have
recovered but but there are still many
ongoing studies looking at how the virus
affects the liver exactly and why
you